Buckingham Palace has released the
official coronation
Otto portraits of King Charles III and
his Queen Camilla now these pictures
Echo Queen Elizabeth's coronation
portraits from 70 years ago for the
photographer though this was not just
another job this was far more personal
he spoke with MTS Taya before his work
was revealed to the world
[Music]
their photos Fit For A King the official
coronation photographs of King Charles
III and queen Camilla along with
Britain's new slim down royal family and
this is the man who captured the
instantly historic images photographer
Hugo bernaz because I like when you look
at a portrait of mine hopefully you'll
be feeling that you're in conversation
with that person bernand is a familiar
face among Britain's upper classes he
spent years photographing High Society
events for the pages of toddler magazine
but it was in 2005 when he was asked to
photograph Charles and Camilla's wedding
at his Ascent into official Royal
photography was cemented so I got my
mother who's a photographer to start
organizing it for me so there was Hugo
the photographer and his family
photographing their family
keeping you to the family Bernard was
asked by Prince William and Kate to
photograph their wedding there's a
really famous photograph
um of the wedding and it's a very
relaxed image it's an image that almost
didn't happen we had three minutes
basically it is the real characters of
every individual that has come through
in that moment what you see in that
picture is real life despite the
pressures of capturing history in the
making Hugo says in the moment he
focuses on just one thing really deep
down spot
oh emotion
you have to draw it out of someone
so if you if you're thinking of too much
your mind is distracted and you can't
connect with a person a connection that
for bernand is very real
so when you ask me what does it look
like to look through the lens and see
King Charles III I see someone I know
already work
which is a really beautiful thing
for CBS mornings I'm imphy's tayab in
London
wow I wasn't expecting that kind of
emotion I wasn't big enough more to him
than just taking a picture well I mean
he's trying to do more than just capture
I'm like he's trying to get something
deeper from it I was amazed that he he
was doing some of those photos he said
in three minutes capturing the humanity
right I liked it I like the pictures
there was chatter in the studio with
people who show him remain nameless who
thought that it looked like something
out of a video Fair no I looked a little
bit like a novelty photo like you know
when we dress up in costumes you can do
the Royals we've all done that we've all
done that but I thought I thought it
captured them beautifully No Doubt